do you think that it was a springboard
to have you miss a year of experience
year of reps and Nick Bosa suddenly pop
up on the screen Oh things that were
working out so I I always told myself I
was a blessing in disguise you know that
ACL and everything and not never got
most out of it so I mean that's a pretty
good trade-off I guess I'm very glad we
have him I don't wish for and 12 on
anybody but it's after going through it
it was nice what it brought us
that's Jimmy Garoppolo and Kyle Shanahan
talking about the impact of last year's
week three season-ending torn ACL for
Jimmy Garoppolo fueling that four and
twelve season and unlocking the
opportunity to get Nick Boesel with the
second overall pick in the draft and
really it was like having the first
overall pick because they weren't gonna
take collar Murray they have Jimmy G
they get Nick Bosa Nick Bosa is great
and it's one of the reasons why this
team is now hosting the NFC Championship
game and Chris and a roundabout way it
proves the value of tanking yeah right a
little bit
you're only you're only one year away
from turning it all around if you get
that special player in the first round
of the draft who can transform your
offense or your defense and we've seen
that with Nick boasts well a hundred
percent I mean first off Bose was
phenomenal I mean Bose was already in
the conversation from one of the best
pass rushers in the sport he's one of
the better defensive players in the
sport they're a different team when he's
not in there and not healthy I mean he's
special
he really is you and I we saw him in
person right this weekend I mean we
talked you know we always joke about
legs and butt holy cow I mean we had to
put both of our legs together to equal
one of his he's just a specimen that way
and so explosive but it's more than that
it's more than the first pick because
it's you know two picks in the top 35 or
36 and there's another contributor there
that if they don't go for in 12 last
year debo Samuel they took him at the
top of the second round so you're not
able to do that without with it within
you know without being four and 12 as
well those are two big-time rookie
contributors on both sides of the ball
where I'm not sure they are where they
are right now without either one of them
yeah and look I am NOT a fan of entering
the season with the mindset that you're
not going to try to win because I think
any of the 32 teams and
any given year can piece together enough
victories to get into playoff discussion
even if they don't only make it just to
be alive and relevant in December but
once you know you're done there really
is no reason to keep winning games yeah
you win by losing because as soon as the
season ends and everything flips from
the standings or you're at the bottom of
your division all of a sudden you're at
the top of the draft and now look you're
you're going to be you know kind of
stuck with whatever the quality is if
the guys coming out any given year but
when you get first dibs in any given
class you have a chance of getting a guy
that's gonna make you better instantly
and dramatically and we've seen that
from the 49ers and oh yeah they didn't
try to go for in 12 but just like Kyle
said hey I wouldn't wish it on anybody
but it's it's led to something pretty
good by having Nick Bosa and this feels
like a team that is gonna be back in
this conversation right for years to
come yeah right it does I mean they're
they're young and talented and they got
all you know a lot of good players on
rookie contract still it's it's the
formula yes for a team that you go well
they're gonna be they got a chance to be
in this final four game you know for the
next five years for sure that mean I
think that's what they've built between
the regime that was there before
Shanahan Lynch and now what they've done
and to add on and to make it even so
much better is great and the other thing
Mike too with Jimmy Garoppolo getting
hurt you know there's some things there
too that help the football team you know
that they knew okay we can't rely on our
quarterback we're not gonna be able to
throw the ball over the lot you know
with Nick Mullens or CJ Beathard so they
had to get tougher it's ours in the run
game they had to learn how to do that
Shanahan he had to push the envelope
afar as far as creativity because he
knew he didn't have like a gamebreaking
superstar type quarterback back there
you knew we had to give them every
schematically he could in that aspect so
those are other things that improve your
football team you know and last year
they played without a franchise
quarterback and still were a pain in the
butt yeah it wasn't a great record but I
think there was a lot of things we saw
as far as going man they're exciting
there's some talent on here you know
watch out for this team this year they
might be in that playoff conversation
and of course they've they far exceeded
that we saw everyone on the
forty-niners starting defensive line get
at least one sack on Saturday against
the Vikings Nick Bosa had two of them
can they do that same thing against
Aaron Rodgers uh not no I don't think
they will be able to I think it's a
great great advantage that the Green Bay
Packers got to play this defense got to
play there in that Stadium once before
they'll know what they're getting
themselves into the second time around I
think they were a little shell-shocked
that first time around won schematically
caught them with a few blitzes and Mike
some twists and stunts that Green Bay
really didn't pick up well and I think
they were caught off guard by just the
talent and the aggression and the
explosiveness of that front so I think
they'll have a better game plan going
forward the offensive line will know
what to expect more I think they'll have
more place to get the ball out of him
Rodgers hands quickly and things like
that to maybe wear out that front for a
little bit and not let them be such a
force in the game like they were the
first time around and perhaps the
biggest challenge your tattoo buddy Kyle
Shanahan has this week is to get his
players to forget about 37.8 right get
them to look at how it happened why it
happened right how it easily could have
gone the other way
and I think the easiest piece of that
for Kyle Shanahan is to focus his guys
on what Aaron Rodgers is capable of
doing that somewhere that I mean he's in
the zone right now right he's fully
aware of his football mortality fully in
possession of his football abilities
going back to his home area yeah taking
on the team he grew up rooting for he is
gonna be dangerous this weekend Chris
Wright well yeah I mean the 49ers are
waking up going oh we already beat this
team and the Green Bay Packers are
waking up with fear every day like I
hope we don't get blown out I hope we
don't get sent home and there's some you
know real stuff to that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports